(Music)
Text: BeatJazz.
BeatJazz is:
1. Live looping,
2. Jazz improvisation
And
3. "Gestural" sound design.
Accelerometers
on each hand
read hand position.
The color of the lights
indicates which sound I am playing.
Red = Drums,
Blue = Bass,
Green = Chords,
Orange = Leads,
Purple = Pads
The mouthpiece
consists of ...
a button,
two guitar picks
and lots of hot glue.
The heads-up display
is a smartphone that displays system parameters.
Why?
To atomize music culture
so that ALL past, present and future genres
can be studied and abstracted, live.
And
"BeatJazzers"
become as common as D.J.'s.
But mostly ...
to MAKE the future
rather than wait for it.
(Applause)